Speaker 1: Donald Trump, Jr's
fiancee. Kimberly GUILFOYLE
absolutely rocked a room full of about 12
people. She is doing everything she can in
this clip to energize the crowd. But when the
camera pans to the crowd, you see there's only
about a dozen or 15 people in the crowd. It's
it's just unbelievable. You couldn't write.
Anything more pathetic than what actually
happened. So listen to this. And if you're only
listening and not watching, understand that when
you hear the crowd, there's like 15 people there.
Speaker 5: All of us in this room have one
message to Joe Biden. It is time to put America
first.
Speaker 1: God,
look at this crowd. A lot of the people don't
even seem to be watching the speech. One, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19,
20, 21, 22, 23. Okay, so there's like 30 people in
a room that could fit maybe like 800 or something
like that. It is shocking how humiliating this is.
Speaker 5: To put common sense.
Speaker 1: All right. And then one other
humiliating moment from Kimberly GUILFOYLE.
As if it wasn't bad enough that she was doing
some kind of show. I guess she has a show on
Rumble now. She did her show from C PAC, and she
tries to sell silver and gold. And she's reading
everything off of a teleprompter to her. Right.
And it's awkward and it's weird and it's strange.
Speaker 5: And I want to
make sure that you guys know
about goes home. Don Jean has been talking about
it. Gold and silver can protect your retirement
savings. Yeah, inflation and dollar devaluation
and only tangible physical inflation. Hedging gold
and silver can help diversify your portfolio.
You've got to have a diversified portfolio.
Speaker 1: Everybody knows that.
Speaker 5: Everyone has helped
thousands of Americans diversify and protect
their retirement savings. Support companies who
support you. It makes sense. Thousand eight And
instead of supporting both companies who hate you
and use your money to further their political
agenda, yeah, go to Kim's metals. It's kind
of catchy. Dot com. To learn more about.
Speaker 1: Kim's metals and dot com. Okay
so there it is and making a very powerful
investment suggestion is Kimberly GUILFOYLE
a completely absurd snapback. I mean you could
say I'm guessing Saturday Night Live can't do
anything with it because it it's a parody of
itself. And Kimberly GUILFOYLE, Ben Carson,
all of these people, Nikki Haley, they are just
debasing themselves relentlessly. And I have to
be honest, I absolutely love to see it. Let's take
a quick break. Remember that all of these clips
will be on our Instagram, which you can find
by searching Instagram for David Pakman show.